If you look at a cookie or a soda versus an
apple, you can be less concerned about the
sugar in an apple.
There's a lot of other things besides just
fructose.
All sorts of bio active compounds, some of
them probably haven't even been discovered
yet, that do positive things to our health.
The soda and the sugar sweetened beverages
have pretty much only one thing in them and
that's the sugar.
From many, many epidemiological studies, we
do know that the people who eat the most fruit
are the healthiest and have least risk for
metabolic disease.
The other thing is, you have to eat a lot
of fruit to consume a comparable amount of
sugar as is in three cans of soda.
Or two cans of soda and two cookies.
Chances are you're not going to be able to
overeat fruit to the point you're going to
have a high sugar diet just from fruit.
Unless you eat a lot of honey, it's actually
heard to be on a high fructose diet if you
are depending on nature only to get your fructose.